Як кампанію почнеш, так її і продовжиш.
Пряме спілкування з суспільством без посередників у вигляді медіа,
на що робили ставку в команді Володимира Зеленського,
поки що залишається в пріоритеті, без особливих змін.
Ще до президентства він не раз заявляв, що на відміну від своїх попередників
не буде часто з’являтися на публіці, а натомість час від часу зніматиме відеоролики-звернення.
Від розлогого інтерв’ю одному з акторів фільму "Слуга народу"
до прогулянки урядовим кварталом -
за час свого президентства Володимир Зеленський спробував різні формати
прямого спілкування з електоратом.
У відео він розповідає про досягнення, проблеми, когось критикує, а когось хвалить.
Щодо кількості переглядів, лайків і коментарів - такі відео дійсно успішні.
Наприклад, лише перший монолог за кермом машини, який журналісти охрестили "інтерв’ю Tesla"
набрав більше двох з половиною мільйонів переглядів.
І це лише на YouTube.
Такий формат популярний передусім тому, що президент поводиться як проста, "своя" людина.
Він звертається напряму до українців
і звітує щодо певних реформ чи законів, які обіцяв втілити ще до виборів.
Таким чином показуючи, що не забув про свої обіцянки і про свого виборця.
Президент також не втрачає нагоди час від часу критикувати окремих чиновників,
стару владу і демонструвати свою єдність з виборцями
проти корумпованої бюрократизованої системи.
Формат дозволяє президентові використовувати неофіційну, просту мову,
загравати до глядача і жартувати, та поводитися по-панібратськи.
Саме тому, за підрахунками Інституту масової інформації,
соцмережі самого Володимира Зеленського набагато популярніші,
ніж, приміром, сторінка Офісу президента, де публікують більш офіційні, сухі пости.
У самого Зеленського у соцмережах читачів у п'ятнадцять разів  більше,
ніж у сторінок Офісу президента, йдеться у звіті ІМІ.
Однак довго пряма розмова з людьми без посередників не протрималась.
Як пишуть медіаексперти, вже у жовтні в Офісі президента визнали брак комунікацій,
особливо у контексті протестів через "формулу Штайнмаєра".
Після короткого брифінгу в середині вересня щодо цієї формули і в Офісі президента,
і сам глава держави майже два тижні зберігали мовчанку.
А це ще більше підігрівало чутки про зраду інтересів України у соцмережах.
Медіаексперти впевнені, що саме цей провал змусив Зеленського
провести пресмарафон, повертаючись таки до традиційних медіа.
Окрім того, попри обіцянки влаштовувати прямий контакт постійно,
таке відео нечасто з'являється у соцмережах президента.
А якщо і з'являється, то із запізненням.
На думку медіаекспертів, Зеленський постійно програє за швидкістю реакції.
Втеча від традиційних медіа до прямого контакту з громадянами,
можливо, і вигідна з популістичної точки зору,
але від цього програє якість інформації, вважають медіафахівці.
Журналісти, які відіграють роль фільтра інформації,
перевірки її на фейк або маніпуляцію, таким чином залишаються поза бортом.
Записати ролик і запостити його в інтернеті - найпростіше.
Таким чином можна уникнути гострих запитань
і заперечень у недостовірності інформації від представників ЗМІ.